What has been decided here?
Years after the verdict that took Lula out of the last presidential election campaign...
...and took him to prison,...
...what has now been decided is that the court that made that decision...
...was not the adequate forum to judge this case.
So, Lula is back in the game, and he regained his political rights,...
...but one possible interpretation here is that this also protects Sergio Moro,...
...the judge who made the decision.
That's because Sergio Moro later became Justice Minister...
...in the government of Jair Bolsonaro.
So, it seems he had a clear and definite interest in the election...
...for which he had rendered Lula ineligible,...
...and it seems from intercepted conversations that in his role as judge,...
...he's also alleged to have been coaching the prosecution side.
So, his partiality, lack of partiality is in question.
Now, that's under investigation.
That investigation may now be halted...
...as a result of the decision taken today by Brazil's supreme court.